uh so I uh I'm a the organizers
but 25 years now
yeah there some combinations of ma
learning for
theing and as you just heard uh it seems
to be an exciting topic these days even
though for me it was exciting topic 5
years ago and
the um the
I I will say there are three
motivations that I'm I'm somehow
distinguishing in into what we are
doing and like most of you here are
probably the motivation like let's
formalize mathematics let let's do math
on computers let's let's
do uh I would call it the QED gam so I
don't know how much you
and any of you uh know about it but uh
some more than 20 years ago there was
this Manifesto and QED Workshop where
people basically wrote up this uh uh
Proclamation why would it be good to to
formalize math for all sorts of
reasons and I would say if you if you
read it I I very much recommend reading
it I think Frank might have it CED so
somewhere on his web pages uh being the
guardian of of of the history of the two
two uh QQ workshops by we did a q
Workshop
U after 20 years 10 years ago right so
it will be like 30 years now uh I I very
much invite you to read it because you
know some for some people it feels new
when when hear all these ideas from I
don't know from some YouTubes of Kev or
whatever but these are
really so so that's that's like one
dream I would
say there are two related dreams to it
and one of the related dreams is the
dream of omnipotent automated reasoning
automated fear improving
proving crazy hard uh mathematical
theorems compon conri
Etc and but that's a dream which is I
would
say equally old like you could even say
that the field of automated here
improving is one of the older fields of
artificial intelligence like like some
of the the logic theories by Simon and
is is today often cited as as the first
AI system ever which may slightly
uh questionable but but it's it's
definitely example of a of a very old uh
AI system and and the field of automated
here improving in the beginnings of AI
especially was really like people like
John McCarthy they very much into this
um stream of AI where you you would
translate sort of hard problems not just
mathematical but scientific into you
would sort of reduce them into
mathematics and you would reduce
mathematics into logic which is like
this this thing which which happened
this with this sort of like it's
Hilbert's
Russell U program at at the beginning of
of the 20 Century and then you would
solve your problems by search right like
by search you would in in a similar way
as as you find the proof of font's Last
Theorem automatically you you would
solve all sorts of other problems I
don't know from physics or whatever but
by reduction to mathematics and to and
that's that's sort of sort of the third
dream like the third dream is the field
the dream of basically
AI solving all sorts of what's say
scientific problems and obviously that
the dream is slightly fuzzier and it's
it's a there everybody today cries I
don't know deep learning or not even
deep learning anymore everybody is
shouting large language mods right
whatever uh but like the the dream of
reducing uh all sorts of scientific and
maybe other problems like for example
John McCarthy has a nice paper from I
beginning of 199s I think uh maybe end
of 1990s about
producing uh legal and political
uh uh proposals to some pseudo proof do
some sort of pseudo pseudo logic and he
he actually motivates it by by the
progress and formal mathematics and the
so so so these are sort of the three
dreams which are somehow out there and
and they are connected in in various
ways right like if we if we manage to
put all of the
math very advanced math
into uh in into some computer deeply
computer understandable for not not just
archive then then we can for example
train uh combinations of various machine
learning and F search uh systems on that
which is like I said what I have been
doing for more than 20
years uh so so that that's just to sort
of brainwash you a bit with don't don't
just focus on formalization of math like
be be aware of the fact that this may be
a part of
something uh equally or even more crazy
and interesting if if sort of QED Q G uh
progresses and like you might have seen
seen this book like the logi comics if
not then then definitely get it and read
it
uh there there is this
nice picture
about uh this the hero of the book is
Russell tell telling his life story and
uh here on the slide he he's saying how
how basically he got inspired by by
light the guy who who is often quoted
for for this calculus the the idea let
us calcul
where basically he envisions that some
sometime in the future we will be able
to to reduce a lot of
our scientific or even
societal uh issues and problems just to
reasoning just to formal calculation way
things like that right so so so that's
actually what what might be sort of
happening today if in the sort of AI and
automated reasoning and and uh
formalization um
programs uh proceed reasonably right
like you you could uh we were discussing
yesterday for example formalization of
law right like we could really today
have a shot at
embedding uh a lot of law which is fuzzy
and natural language based into into
logic in in the S of same way as as we
are trying to in mathematics into I
don't know Le or
whatever okay so now I burn like 10
minutes of my talk so now you see that
the size will definitely uh definitely
not reach its end uh and like this is
just like one
way how how we could sort of do do this
uh process of let's say at least
automated automating right like so so we
know that uh well we we don't know
exactly what it is that mathematicians
are doing well maybe you some of you
know some some of you are pretty good
mathematicians here uh but like the the
fuzzy idea is that we have a lot of
these pattern matching
analogizing learning uh inducing
Knowledge from examples capabilities and
then mathematicians or so are pretty
good at deductive reasoning at knowing
how to compose pieces of knowledge into
into proofs and into things that we can
really proof check today and sometimes
these things are very surprising like
they can be surprising both positively
and negatively they they can really
bring you new new knowledge and there
seem to be some feedback cles between
these two processes so so if you are not
succeeding in composing CU proofs maybe
you will
from your failur and maybe your next
attempt will will be
better and obviously we we do this
knowing a lot of stuff like they have
beaten into a lot of textbooks of of
math Etc so if we want
to somehow start doing this on on
computers that that there is one good um
resource that we we could sort of use
for uh
training the sort of automated
mathematicians or starting the research
and training these automative
mathematicians and that's exactly these
SL liaries of formal proofs that have
existing for decades today I would say I
I
started five years ago with the mear
mathematical Library which already like
in 2000 had like 700 mathematic articles
in it about all all sorts of
mathematical areas and like you you
could really try to take such a big
formal Corpus today I don't know
Isabelle Co clean would
be le ones and try to do or develop some
strong automated here improving machine
learning
capabilities so so so the rest of the
story is basically some some s attempts
in this direction like mostly talking
about our work like the work that me and
my team have been doing and just one
funny picture from this logic Comics
book like
uh when I started to do this not not
just be other
people there like today AI in in the
minds of many people is the machine
learning
and uh I would say
uh the the two communities the the sort
of formal reasoning the the sort of
precise logic uh community and the
Machine learning uh
Community uh don't um get together too
well like there there is sort of a lot
of resistance from both sides like to
today the situation is is much better
but uh that that is sort of
Suspicion which which can be slightly
traed back to to to a famous debate
between these two two giants of matics
which this this this picture
from where that is the the sort of
Hilbert Russell and frag Etc program
which really brought us the symbolic
Logic the
formalization you could even say
computers like computers are basically
symbolic logic machines and then there
is the sort of intuition based uh
approach which sort of
pank would be a sort of a example here
which obviously doesn't mean that he
couldn't do proofs but but like the fear
that the formality is sort of taking us
in the in the wrong direction right and
um the these two two views you can
encounter quite often still to today
when you are trying to combine some some
precise formal reasoning with some sort
of
imprecise
statistical machine learning for example
or some some sort of inductive pattern
matching Etc so so I would say it's not
a bug it's probably a feature like like
the humans
have uh
somehow all these capabilities and they
somehow combine them but the the sort of
learning and induction from examples is
is a very important capability the the
sort of capability to manipulate symbol
and do deductions is also an extremely
like like I said we we wouldn't be able
to program computers right like if we if
we didn't didn't have that uh but but I
would say it's the the field is very
interesting just because of this or it's
it's one of the big reasons why why the
field is quite interesting because it
sort of forces the two camps in AI to
somehow come to terms you cannot do
theorems just by Machine learning or you
cannot like to learn just
by uh I'll skip one I like an
interesting interesting guy in in this
exp Jing who who probably faced some of
these issues himself while like being
basically the guy who who brought us
computers or one of the guys who brought
us computers and who is particularly
famous for the Hing problem and the
decidability of
first uh together this
church uh
and uh
you you could sort of see him as going
through some sort of change during the
second world war when he was working on
as
Enigma right like hacking um hacking the
coding systems of this country uh and
like he can really be seen as not only
the guy who brought us computers but
also the guy who very much brought us
artificial intelligence and in this uh
1950 Pap Computing machinery and
intelligence where he sort of debates
like why machines wouldn't be able to
think and introduces the during test and
for example he has these SCS right like
what what would be the best Fields uh so
so this is the last section called
learning Machines of this 1950 the
foundational paper on AI where he says
like what would be the best fields to
start training this learning learning
machines on and he he for example
proposes to to
start training systems that would be
playing chess or some other games which
by the way like each of you have seen
this Alpha go and Alpha zero became
really very uh real recently and the the
question is why would we limit ourselves
to chess or some boring limited games
why wouldn't we do this with MAF which
is basically a game when you do it on a
computer in your Le or Isabelle or Co or
or H uh it is a game like FR always says
this is a this is a game for me right
it's a sort of addictive game for uh
some of us I would say I'm looking at
Mario U so so can we really train a
superum game for like like let's say we
can train it today for goal um so so
that's very question but I would say
currently we cannot like you shouldn't
sort of trust the the headlines
which for some six seven years have now
been announcing a breakthrough in
machines overtaking humans and
Mathematics about every summer du during
some crazy summer Quant or nature season
so so no
currently there are sort of
isolated areas like for example
equational algebra where machines or
automated the pr have been very good for
let's say three four decades uh by now
where people can prove open conjectures
that mathematicians cannot but I have
say in in the general heart know therat
Last Theorem style uh mathematics the
the technology certainly isn't on on a
human level to
today um I'll skip some some of this
motivation because I I talked about it
you you probably know I you have heard
it yesterday but this is B some sort of
Blue Sky AI which is today really
bombarding you from all sorts
of newspaper titles but but one reason
how I was getting fun before with this
AI hype wave came was that these these
systems that we are building for example
hammer or or the Tactical Systems can
really assist uh people like you people
who do want to formalize mathematics and
there is this bunch of projects like for
proof of the cap conjecture fire theorem
etc
etc where if we if we make it make it
work in and like Isabel and sled is one
of the biggest success of proof
automation uh then then we really manag
to speed
the
formalization modification in these
systems so so this is probably the slide
I spend most of my time to control the
time um so so what do we do today what
what we have been been uh doing
for these uh last years can be
divided into couple of branches well
like you could say that one way how to
divide it is basically on which level
you combine the the machine learning
with with the let's say CRM proving
there is some
othering uh
technology and what I have here are some
sort of examples of high level guidance
lowlevel guidance midlevel guidance and
some other topics like for example
I know Theory exploration
feedback uh the learning and proving Al
the formalization which is like taking
some natural language latch text on some
paper and trying
to make it automatically p in your
favorite pref system and I I say the
high level thing is probably the
earliest and easiest and also was it was
the most pressing one when uh let's say
20 years ago when somebody like me or L
pson started to take these big corpora
of Isabel or misar and we really wanted
to prove a new conjecture on top of them
I know misar could have at the time uh
something like 30,000 lemas in it and
you simply couldn't feed 30,000 plas to
automated theor per of the time they
they they weren't constructed they were
typically working it's like 4 to 20 EXs
so so what you had to come up with was
some uh method that would from this big
knowledge this big collection of
textbooks that exists in some formal uh
form uh extract the the most relevant
computers for your uh know premises for
for for your new conjecture and that
that became a pretty well established
Topic in machine learning forf improving
called premise selection where you
basically construct the machine learning
task by saying well hey I already have
like 30,000 PS proofs in in my in my
library so I can do some painting some
machine learning on on them because each
of them has a conjecture and each of
them some space of available premises
from which only a few were actually
useful so so whatever is my favorite
machine learning method I can try to
train it on that and when I see a new
conjecture I can try to run it and and
see how much it helps me to improve the
next conure so so so these these premise
selectors are today Prett
standard um parts of for example the
sledgehammer uh system in is AEL where
it's it's running a very fast machine
learning methods like na Bay so
neighor uh
the maybe I'll s of skip the other high
level uh tasks and give you just
examples of the lowlevel stuff so so the
lowlevel stuff
is sort of the opposite of the high
level stuff in the sense that you can
take with these automated Ser provs
which are really like you you probably
didn't hear a talk about those um yet uh
but in some sense the the field of
automated reasoning is split into you
could say interactive your improving and
automate the improving so so in
interactive the improving you you really
do it manually and you hope that uh the
system people will provide you the suit
Automation in automated you're improving
you sort of hope you are constructing
systems which are really trying to do it
all for you obviously it all very often
fails uh so so these are highly
efficient symbolic uh systems which take
some conjecture and aoms and they use
some calculus like for example T
calculus super position resolution
calculus and they we we we know
typically that they are complete so we
know that if you give them infinite
amount of time they they will give you a
proof provided that that is a proof uh
but it's typically they encounter some
sort of combinatorial explosion because
like this is obviously hard right like
the task is sem
decidable um so so the sort of ambitious
thing the sort of low level guidance you
can do is to in instead of using
whatever are some reprogrammed htic uh
for for guiding these automated the
improver like typically like the the
very high level picture of how how these
systems work for example in the
superposition resolution calculus is
that I give you AUM and a conjecture I
negate the conjecture and now from the
exms and the negated conjecture I try
I'm trying to derive a contradiction and
the way I'm doing it is that I qualify
everything I I put it into sort
Clauses and now I'm for example using
the resolution and rewriting rules to to
get to contradiction which is the TIC
CLA the TIC Closs is a disjunction of
zero
literals and theistic could be that you
prefer the Clauses which have like fewer
literals in them because that sort of
gets you to the empty clause which is
zero withs but obiously it's just a
horis because the problem is very hard
some decidable so sometimes you really
need to generate very big
Clauses so so the way how you would like
to plug in machine learning into it is
that maybe you have a big collection of
problems that you have solved already
like for example you can extract them
from from these um big IP libraries
Maybe you can around the automated theur
and provs at least on some of them and
and prove them and then when you unleash
this automated theor and pro on a new
problem it will sort of be guided by by
some trained machine Learner in saying
what it should do like like which of
these inferences it it should prefer in
particular situations when sort of
running into situations that sort of
look like some previous situations that
already encountered it might not do too
much sort of blind search in those
situations and instead go sort of in in
the direction that actually turn out to
be be so this is
ambitious because for example if you
throw I know deep neural metri or large
language models into it then this
something like CH GPT will probably do
like one inference per second which is
horribly slow right like like the the
atps are very F symbolic engines that
can do 100,000 inference per second so
so if you if you are perfectly correct
then then fine if the proof takes 100
steps then it will take you 100 seconds
but like that typically doesn't happen
right like because this is a new problem
hard problem you need to do some search
and some back there so so for for the
sort of lowlevel guidance of of these
highly efficient um Auto the theorum PR
you typically need to very
carefully do choose your tradeoffs
between the speed and the uh performance
of of the machine learning methods which
which you are guiding this and sometimes
this leads to like multi-layered
architectures for example you may have
some some very fast learning
architectures at the top and some
slowish architectures to to do the sort
of last step uh
is uh because this is so hard people
have successfully developed something in
between the these two approaches so so
the the premise section sort of easy
from this point of view because you call
the machine learner only once when it
tells you what to select from from this
large mathematical library and then you
just give it to to the automated F
through to the hammer and it sort of
goes with it right like you can can call
it uh this I don't know 10 different
suggestions and then call the automate
10 times but but it's still very few
calls to to the machine leine which can
be expensive it can be some crazy large
mle Network and if you spend one second
on that that's that's fine because then
the
automated arounds I don't know for 10
seconds uh so the med level guidance is
some sort
of approach
in in trying to sort of get the best of
of the Two Worlds and I would say the
the biggest example of of this midlevel
approach is today uh basically machine
learning based guidance of interactive
PR like clock
is all uh
where
the the machine learner is is called to
to recommend the Tactical steps that
that you are doing in in in these intive
PR especially the Tactical ones like in
the sort of Decor ones that is sort of
more uh complicated but if you look at
something like for example or hall
or lean it's it's relatively easy to
train something and already very simple
methods like K where extremely well on
this on on a large repository of proofs
where basically it looks at the proof
state but the current proof State and it
tells you well now use induct or
whatever now use rewrite or not now use
the me tactic or what in PVS right um so
so this um this means that the machine
learner doesn't need to be so fast as as
in the low level guidance
because um you you don't do these
tactical steps so often as the sort of
lowlevel uh steps in the automated heing
fod you can spend reasonable time on
that and then what you have to do and
what what is actually quite technically
challenging in reasonably Advanced
interactive is to combine it with some
sort of proof search in in in these
techn
which is really nonrival engineering
work so so I would say today that there
is a lot of experiments like like with
this technology
in but there is only like very few
systems that actually work and the users
can experiment because like the
engineering work is is really nonrival
to sort of make it uh useful for example
make it make it learn from from the
formalization that the user is doing so
so as the user is introducing new
Concepts and news Etc it you you need to
do something right like if you only
train language model on on everything
that is already in the library well what
do you do when when the user introduced
10 new Concepts like will you retrain a
large language model for one year or
like you you can try like so so so that
that is sort of a lot of these
engineering issues but but I would say
this is like a very U
rewarding um field to to
explore uh okay so this was a bit of the
overview and I can probably
go in some of the
demos um well maybe before I go there I
I don't know how much
from probably Peter kast and uh manual a
St you you may have uh seen that there
are these things called hammers like
Sledgehammer in Isabel and the whole n
system today is one big hammer right
like you you you only call automated the
fous steered by some sort of premise
selection so so this is really uh in in
the Isabel system like a very powerful
and used uh method for
assisting uh assisting the
users and it has been done in all sorts
of other systems but it's by far most
used in
in and the the idea is so sort of I
already explained to some extent so you
have a proest ST which in this case
maybe is Hall something in high
logic big Library
Etc and then you you do have some
current gold that you want to Pro in in
the system formulated in sort of more
Rich uh logic uh then then what the
hammer does is that it takes your goal
and and the whole theories that you have
available and it does two things it
selects or proposes by all all sorts of
methods some of them the machine
learning uh the most relevant premises
for for this current goal that you have
and then it translates from from the
sort of richer logic which you are in
like for example in Cammer this is
really not trival because you need to
translate from type Theory to to pH
logic or so that's even in is which is
sort of Simply TI of polymorphic H logic
that there are really many possible
options how how to do the translation
from from the logic to First all logic
and once you have done it you shift it
over to these powerful first order
automated theorem provs like e or
vampire in this case and you hope for
the best you hope that these things will
will give you a proof if that
happens you you try to reconstruct the
ATP proof into an ITP proof which will
go through the terel of of of this U
secure um formal proof system like is so
so sometimes what can happen is that
there is a buck in the the ulated which
are sort of less strict about
the the
security or what can happen is that some
of these
translations are un because they are
sort of trying to simplify things so so
that they give better chances to be
automated here and PR but the price is
is the sometimes the automated Prov can
sort of abuse the simplification and
find a proof which is actually not a
proof in the
origin but but anyway like these methods
have been developed quite a bit and uh
some 10 years
ago uh they could do like for 40 to 45
uh person on on these various uh systems
uh libraries and quite quite
recently about
60% on on the me Library by basically
putting all all sorts of machine
learning methods into these uh lowlevel
uh systems but but also by developing a
useful machine lar methods for the task
of Prem selection uh so so that's just
just for you to know that in some of
these systems in particular Isabel and
in particular Nao if you play with
them uh and P a hammer or
Sledgehammer some of these things are
happening sort of behind the scenes and
they they sort of might be happening to
you also in some other theor pries like
I think that there is a push in lean to
to integrate
automated
f
um maybe I'll now show you at least one
demo of how
the Tactical guidance work but I'm not
sure if this is visible it's probably
not too visible
right well I'll I'll try to run it
anyway whole screen will help sorry
whole screen will help
yeah
see and this is available so so so this
is the uh tactical um ttic learning
guide tactical
theoy the first system which which
really made it fully usable and also
made it uh quite strong uh which is
called tactic to by Tio go uh
so what he is doing here is saying I
want to TTT this particular
goal then the TT is loading a lot of
previous tactics and theorems and then
what what it's doing when it sort of
spits out these ASM Sy Tech
and is that it's basically doing some
sort of Monte Carlo research Guided by
by the um knowledge learned from from
these
previous uh 3 3,000 theorems and pro
basically so so after occasionally it
actually finds finds the proof and then
then it sort of spits it out uh so this
is sort of the mold of inter direction
that
you
oops that you that you
get uh is this now now you see that it's
thinking really hard
[Music]
uh so so now again it tried to prove
some theorem about uh mapping something
on on a
list and again like
it after doing the resou search Guided
by by the paint machine learner it it
finished so so this is today I I think
such systems exist in Co and maybe I
don't know what the situation in in Lina
and they call and whole life and I they
are sort of more experimental than than
the hammer systems but like for for
these complicated Tactical Systems this
is like a very useful thing to have and
some of you might consider Ling on them
like it's it's non-rival but it's it's a
like a so so for example this tactic to
system can prove again something like 60
to 70% of the whole whole four uh
Library so I guess I will I will stop
here and uh I I guess if you if you want
to hear about uh some of these other
things you see on on slide slide 11 then
you can ask me or I can be another talk
that's it thank you
yes